c'est une petite affiche rouge vif qui
revêt tout un symbole pour la foire de
tours le pass and iter est finalement
abandonné après de nombreux
rebondissements vacciner ou pas cette
cacophonie a perturbé les visiteurs nous
on est vacciné donc on l'avait
effectivement mais je comprends que pour
les gens qui ne l'avait pas ça doit être
compliqué la dernière sinon je suis pas
vacciné donc forcément j'aurais pas pu
venir et puis montrer sa x terra tout on
n'a pas pu se faire vacciner non pas par
choix mais parce que ben on ne pouvait
pas forcément dans les temps un peu
moins de 300 exposants sont présents
cette année pour le centenaire
dès le premier jour de la foire ils ont
vu les conséquences du passage iter est
pour eux mêmes après son abandon
vendredi soir le mal est fait forcément
il ya un gros impact pour nous qui avons
quand même une grosse structure est donc
un gros manque à gagner il faut dire les
choses comme elles sont pour moi ça
enlève ça va enlever deux tiers des
personnes qui vont visiter g désolé
d'être réaliste peut être dur mais juste
à quelques mots près arriver à enlever
deux cas des personnes entre les stands
d'exposition et le village gastronomique
la foire de tours attire en moyenne
chaque année 320 mille personnes la
manifestation avait déjà souffert de
multiples reports duo comique 19 alors
le principal objectif est de rassurer
les visiteurs
on essaye de redire aux gens en plus en
venant à la fois vous êtes dans un
endroit extrêmement privilégié s'il ya
un endroit dans notre région où on va
pas attraper de maladie c'est chez nous
parce que les allées sont larges
parce que nous sommes sur 19 hectares
donc et que nous respectons les
protocoles sanitaires mais l'impact a
été là c'est clair reste une petite
satisfaction avoir amené un peu plus de
clarté pour les organisations des futurs
foire dans le reste de la france